what's up party people it is Jerry it's
your boy it's your man it's your uncle
yeah so check it out I'm chilling
outside waiting for ryan and i figured
now would be a perfect opportunity to
talk about a little movie I saw recently
my mustache is out of control so
recently I was treated to a screening of
a movie called welcome to the jungle I
am using my hand a lot recently uh some
friends took me to see welcome to the
jungle which many of you might know as
the new jean-claude Van Damme movie um
which it kind of is this movie is about
sort of a team-building exercise gone
wrong um just texted me it's basically
this movie is sort of about like a
team-building exercise gone awry a bunch
of coworkers are sent to this sort of
wilderness survival ISM thats led by
jean-claude van damme who's like really
tough and ex-military and Blair any
ensues and this is a pretty cool movie
it's got adam brody from the OC what you
say that's you only men cause you did
what you say because it is adam brody is
in this as the lead character and then
Rob Huebel who you might recognize from
UCB and a whole bunch of other things
and then a bunch of different comedic
people you might recognize Christian
scholars in this dennis haysbert pops up
for a minute jean-claude van damme is in
it but this movie is a lot of fun man
it's interesting it's it's the kind of
comedy we see a lot nowadays but with a
little more of an indie edge like it's
totally an independent movie the guy who
wrote this movie whose name is a is jeff
hoffman at least according to IMDb this
is his first writing credit and the
director Rob Meltzer and think it's his
first feature or at least first you know
feature of this sort it's well done you
know it's it's it's it has that sort of
independent sort of understated miss
this sort of earnestness like it's not
quite zany in your face all the time it
still got a lot of that sort of banter e
humor and it's got that slightly
absurdist sense of humor but it's also
really totally varied in some cool ways
I mean basically they get stranded on
this island when they find out that not
everything about this trip is as it
should be let's put it that way not
everything is on the on the level and so
they're basically forced to actually
forage and survive on a deserted island
full of animals and things over the
course of the movie and stuff like you
know you watch society break down it's
almost like Lord of the Flies in a sense
and then so you watch these people get
all primitive and they start to form
tribes and they sort of split into two
camps you know one which is the insane
just survivalist O'Brien's going hello
over the course of the movie as this
trip goes more and more awry you know
like they're forced to divide up into
two camps you know one of which is led
by adam brody who's already sort of the
guy around the office who's smart and
creative and and genial but he keeps
getting trampled over by you know other
people with bigger personalities like
Rob Huebel who is sort of his foil
throughout the movie and who basically
goes to the exact opposite side of the
spectrum and it's interesting because
there are certain moments and and this
is where the direction get school is
like there are certain moments where
they're doing these tribal things and
they're like dancing around fires and
like sacrificing stuff and the direction
like you you actually do feel
uncomfortable like the way it's captured
and the way the music is and the way
they approach those elements is
completely in earnest and completely
committed and so it's a funny movie but
it's also like jarring at times when
it's appropriate so that variance is
really cool you know it's a nifty little
indie comedy the performances are all
good you know Adam Brody is really
likable everybody is funny everybody is
on point and it's a lot of fun as a
movie the one thing that um that might
take some people back I went into this
not knowing a thing about it other than
jean-claude van damme Vezina and to say
it's the new jean-claude Van Damme movie
is kind of misleading only because he's
definitely in it he's definitely a
prominent character let's just say that
his he doesn't have his
much screen time due to certain plot
points however he is so funny in this
movie and I really hope he does more
stuff like this because jean-claude van
damme is really good with comedy in this
movie and I really hope he starts to do
more of this kind of work you do wish
she was on screen more but the rest of
the movie is good enough and the rest of
the actors hold their own enough that
it's okay and whenever jean-claude van
damme is on screen it is a treat because
he's still badass but when it's a little
more over-the-top and what he's laughing
about it makes it that much more
enjoyable so if you get a chance I'd say
definitely check this movie out it's a
lot of fun it's got a cool indie edge to
it but it's also you know got a lot of
humor and and banter and some really
cool sort of direction and stuff like
that the writing is funny and sharp all
the performances are good in their
various comedic elements and everything
everybody's you know it's just it's a
it's a solid little indie comedy and I
hope more people see it because it's a
lot of fun and like I said I really hope
jean-claude Van Damme takes more work
like this because he is so good at it um
so yeah if you've seen it definitely you
know hit up the comments box and let me
know what you think but yeah that's it
until next time like and subscribe and
all that jazz check us out on all the
various social forums and I will see you
next time welcome to the jungle cheers